Schön.
Hallo, schön und guten Tag. Mein Name ist Topgös. Ich bin zuständiger Erzinfusiver. Wie heißen Sie das?
Frau Doktor, mein Name ist Thomas Berthold.
Thomas, ich freu mich Herr Berthold.
Könnte Sie bitte Ihren Vorunternamen büchtern?
Vornamens Thomas, schreibt sich Thom-a-s. Der Nachname ist Berthold. Schreibt sich Be-r-t-h-o-l-d. Berthold.
Vielen Dank, Herr Berthold. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt, Frau Doktor.
30. Herr Berthold, wissen Sie aktuell, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ich wiege mich regelmäßig. Ich wiege 70 kg und bin 1,85 m groß.
85 kg groß? Okay.
Herr Berthold, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für mich werde abends?
Ja, Frau Doktor, folgendes. Ich habe seit gestern Vormittag, gerade seit über 6-3 Stunden, kann man so sagen,
dass man starke Bauchschmerzen, die kommen und gehen.
Und ich muss auch seit gestern ständig erbrechen.
Das ist mein Hauptproblem.
Dazu muss ich aber sagen, ich bin bekannter Kron-Patient.
Ich habe ein haupts-Kron.
Ich bin auch in einem anderen Krankenhaus normalerweise in Betreuung.
Aber dieses Problem ist jetzt neu seit gestern Vormittag.
Herr Berthold, zeigen Sie bitte, wo genau Ihre Schmerzen sind.
Also eigentlich so richtig in der Mitte vom Bauch?
In der Mitte.
Und wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalapone?
Das ist unterschiedlich. Die werden so weltenartig mehr und werden wieder besser.
Da gibt es auch mal Phasen ohne Schmerzen.
Aber wenn Sie nach dem maximalen Schmerz fragen, wenn das ganz stark kommt,
dann sind sie mindestens 7-8.
Okay.
Könntest du bitte beschreiben, wie sich diese Schmerzen sind?
Wir haben schon gesagt, dass wir sie auf einer Schmerzkalapone haben.
Ja, sie sind schon kampfartig.
Oder kampfartig.
Ja, sie sind schon kampfartig und wehnartig.
Ja, kommen und gehen dann wieder.
Ja, kampfartig.
Und wehnen.
Und ich kann diese Schmerzen nicht mehr aus.
Eigentlich kann man sagen, tut dann der ganze Bauch weh.
Ganz über.
Aber keine Rücken-Schmerzen.
Im Rücken habe ich keine Schmerzen vor Doktor.
Ganz über.
Herr Bert, ich habe schon gesagt, Morbus Crohn.
Ja, Morbus Crohn.
Habt ihr früher einiges über die Schmerzen?
Also ich hatte, die Diagnose ist vor ungefähr 1,5 Jahren gestellt worden.
Da hatte ich Bauchschmerzen.
Die waren aber ein bisschen anders, muss ich sagen.
Nicht so wie jetzt.
Ich hatte dann auch Durchfall gehabt.
Und teilweise auch Fieber und andere Symptome.
Das ist ein bisschen anders.
Also das ist nicht so wie vor 1,5 Jahren.
Ich habe dann auch immer wieder mal Schübe gehabt,
wo sie die Probleme waren.
Aber das ist ein bisschen anders, finde ich.
Wie ist Ihre Krankheit, Morbus Crohn?
Ist gut angestellt bis hier bis...
Also am Anfang war es schwierig.
Da sind mehrere Medikamente probiert worden.
Ich musste dann operiert werden auch 2-mal.
Weil da, sag ich mal, Engstellung waren und Strukturen.
Also ich musste dann dünn-darm entfernt werden.
Teilweise viel.
Also das am Anfang war es schwierig.
Aber in den ersten 6 Monaten habe ich fast durchgehend Probleme gehabt.
Seit ungefähr 3-4 Monaten habe ich aber jetzt da keine Beschwerden gehabt.
Also keine größeren Beschwerden.
Immer wieder mal ein bisschen dünner Stuhl, aber keine Schmerzen,
keinen Durchfall, keinen Fieber.
Also 3-4 Monaten ging es mir eigentlich gut.
Herr Bergtholt, besuchen Sie Ihren Gastroenterologen regelmäßig, oder?
Ich bin einmal im Monat bei Ihnen momentan.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen, Morbus Crohn?
Also jetzt in der Erhaltung, nachdem es jetzt gebremst worden ist,
habe ich jetzt Azatio Pirin als Medikation.
Azatio Pirin.
Okay.
Nur einmal, oder?
Einmal 75 Milligramm, ja.
75 Milligramm, mein Gott.
Und das ist jetzt die Dosis seit ungefähr 2 Monaten, die ich habe.
200.
Nehmen Sie auch Cortison-Tableten?
Nicht mehr, das ist abgehört worden dann, ja.
Seit vielleicht anderthalb Jahren nehmen Sie Azatio Pirin, oder?
Am Anfang waren es andere Medikamente, erstmal mit Cortison.
Und dann habe ich dann eine Kombination bekommen mit Azatio Pirin und Remicade.
Aber jetzt zuletzt nur noch seit wie gesagt 3-4 Monaten Azatio Pirin
nur alleine als Medikation gegen Crohn.
Herr Bertolt, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe gemessen extra.
Gut.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, es ist dann die GR-Brechen-Seh.
Und starke Bauchschmerzen ist Ihnen schon übel.
Ja, ja.
Und ist Ihnen schwindelig auch?
Also wenn ich stark erbreche, ist vielleicht schwindelig,
aber sonst habe ich damit jetzt nicht so ein Problem.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Durchfälle gerade?
Wie viele Mal müssen Sie Schulgang?
Also gar nicht eigentlich.
Also die letzten Monate, 1-2 Monate habe ich damit keine großen Probleme.
Also einmal pro Tag nur Schulgang.
Gab es Blut in Stuhl, beispielsweise gestern, oder?
Ja, ich habe es gestern.
Ich habe es gestern.
Also gestern hatte ich keinen Schulgang,
der letzte Schulgang ist jetzt 3 Tage her bei mir.
Sie sind jede 3 Tage einmal Schulgang?
Also normalerweise nicht,
aber jetzt habe ich seit 3 Tagen keinen Schulgang gehabt.
Der letzte Schulgang war normal.
Also es ist immer ein bisschen dunkel,
weil ich Eisentabletten einnehme.
Aber das ist die ganze Zeit schon so.
Okay, Eisentabletten.
Seit wann nehmen Sie Eisentabletten?
Seitdem ich die Eisentabletten habe,
habe ich sie schon seit fast Beginn von der Kronendiagnose.
Seit einem Jahr.
Nehmen Sie einmal?
Einmal pro Tag, ja, unter Milligramm,
der Rosanot.
Deswegen Ihren Stuhl, Tierstuhl,
dunkel Stuhl.
Ja, dunkel, ja.
Aber Sie haben normalerweise 7 Tage Schulgang,
aber Sie haben gesagt,
3 Tage haben Sie nicht Schulgang.
Also ich habe es schon seit 3 Tagen,
aber Sie haben nicht Schulgang gehabt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Es ist nicht so gut.
Und ich muss unterbrechen
und sofort Ihren, ich denke, es ist ein Notfall.
Ich muss Ihren Bauch untersuchen
und sofort einen Ultraschall durchgeführt werden.
Und ich werde vielleicht eine serugische OP-Planung machen.
Okay, alles klar.
Und eine Monitor-Archilesen für Sie.
Genau, okay.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen aussteigen?
Momentan geht es, ja.
Es geht es momentan, ja.
Du hast ja auch noch ein paar Tage einigen.
Also nur Parazethamone hatte ich zu Hause,
habe ich angenommen, aber das hat nicht viel geholfen.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Ich habe 5 Milligramm, 2 Tabletten habe ich genommen,
mehrfach jetzt 2 Mal.
Heute Morgen nur?
Gestern Abend, heute Morgen auch, ja.
Gestern und heute Morgen.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Momentan ist es schlecht, ja.
Aber sonst, bis vor 2 Tagen war eigentlich einigermaßen normal.
Okay, haben Sie schon bemerkt,
in letzter Zeit abgenommen?
Vorher viel abgenommen, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, seit ungefähr 3, 4 Monaten
halte ich mein Gewicht jetzt.
Ich habe sogar zugenommen ein bisschen.
Okay, gerade keine problematischen für Sie.
Nicht so, nein, in diesen Monaten nicht.
Okay, per ste.
Wie essen Sie, Herbert Holt?
Haben Sie als gewogene Ernährung immer beachten, oder?
Also seit dieser Diagnose muss ich genau gucken, was ich esse.
Und ich habe bestimmte Sachen, die ich nicht vertrage.
Es ist dann auch bei mir dann auch Laktose in Toleranz
festgestellt worden, unter der Krone Erkrankung.
Also ich muss schon genau achten, wie ich esse und was ich esse, ja.
Okay, per ste.
Aber hat gut geklappt in den letzten Monaten.
Wie äußert sich diese Laktose und Toleranz?
Also ich bekomme dann Bauchschmerzen, wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt
bestimmte Sachen esse.
Das habe ich gemerkt, aber da...
Nein, nein, nee.
Oder Laktose festgestellt.
Herbert Holt, haben Sie die andere Bechverden?
Kopfschmerzen im Mund, after lesionen, oder Gelenkschmerzen?
Habt ihr es aktuell nicht?
Ja, okay. Sie haben keine Brustatemnot, Husten oder Herzrasen, Herzklopfen, Erdstorben.
Ich habe keine Probleme damit.
Leiden Sie an Morbuskron und Dr. Inteneras, sonst noch etwas? Noch andere kronische Erkrankungen?
Also wegen dieses Morbuskron, ich hatte vor zwei Jahren schon mal Probleme mit Analfisteln und auch Verianalabstäster, das ist damals operiert worden.
Aber das war vor der Diagnose von Morbuskron gewesen.
Vor der Diagnose?
Ja.
Ansonsten habe ich keine anderen Erkrankungen gehabt bisher.
Und für diese Analfisteln, für andere Erkrankungen?
Also vor zwei Jahren ungefähr.
Also halb bis Jahr, neun Monate vor der Diagnose Morbuskron.
Und sie, vor zwei Jahren, sie wegen Analfisteln operiert worden?
Ja.
Analfisteln?
Analfisteln, Verianalabstäster.
Nun ist das ja.
Leiden Sie an, beispielsweise Schildrüsen über unter Funktionen oder Diabetes mellt zu Typ 1?
Nein, ist nicht festgestellt worden, dass es kontrolliert worden.
Auch Schildrüsen Funktionen war zuletzt gut gewesen.
Und Sie nehmen regelmäßig Asiatiopin, sonst noch andere?
Ja, also Vitamin D ist mir empfohlen worden, da nehme ich 20.000 Einheiten pro Woche.
Eisentapetten, habe ich gesagt.
Und seit der Operation, haben Sie Doktor Mirim von euch auch regelmäßig Vitamin B12 Spritzen bekommen,
soll er sich bekommen, die jetzt einmal im Monat, die Vitamin B12 Spritzen bei den Gastronomidenbogen.
Und ich nehme auch noch Folsore ein.
Ich nehme auch Folsore ein.
Vitamin B, in der Gesassfilat, intremskulare?
Ja, in den Arm, ja.
Folsore Tableten, einmal morgens oder?
Einen morgens, ja.
Okay, verstehe.
Sie haben Laktose intolerant.
Und Sie haben andere Allergie und Verträgtigkeit?
Also es gibt ein paar Sachen, die ich beim ersten Problem bekommen, aber es sind keine Allergie, sonst bekannt.
Und Medikamenteallergie oder?
Auch nicht, nein.
Okay.
Erachn Sie, Herr Bertor?
Ich habe geraucht, das ist aufgehört seit der Diagnose her.
Ja, anderthalb Jahren auch.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Danke schön.
Es ist aber super entscheidend.
Dopfer, wie viele Zigaretten brauchen Sie?
Das waren Päckchen pro Tag, ungefähr.
Hab ich geraucht.
Seit wann?
Ich habe angefangen mit so 18, vielleicht, mit sagen, 10 Jahre, ungefähr, würde ich sagen.
Verstehe, Herr Bertor, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke keinen Alkohol, vertrage ich nicht mehr.
Davor aber so?
Selten mal, also ich war nie Alkohol.
Okay, verstehe.
Herr Bertor, nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich, es ist eine routinmäßige Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, nehme ich nicht.
Gut.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Die leben noch, ja.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Ja, haben auch ein paar Krankheiten.
Also die Mutter hat Diabetes und hat Rheuma.
Alte Diabetes, mein Sie?
Bitte?
Alte Diabetes?
Ja, die hat es im Alte erst bekommen, ja vorher hat sie keine Arzt.
Und der Vater hat es.
Wie ist Ihre Mutter diese Krankheit, die angestellt?
Vom Diabetes.
Und wie ist Ihre Vater?
Der hat nur Hochdruck, er hat auch schon mal einen Herzinfarkt gehabt vor 2-3 Jahren.
Er hat auch eine Diabetes-Farminge, die er in der Diabetes-Farminge hat.
Und wie ist Ihre Mutter?
Die ist jetzt knapp 60.
Und wie ist Ihre Vater?
Der hat nur Hochdruck, er hat auch schon mal einen Herzinfarkt gehabt vor 2-3 Jahren.
Er hat auch geraucht, muss man sagen.
Also das sind so seine Probleme, die ich kenne.
Wie ist Ihre Vater gerade gesund?
Ja, er ist jetzt im Frühruhstand, also so weit stabil.
Wie alt ist er?
Der ist jetzt 63.
63?
Und Ihre Mutter ist 80.
Nein, meine Mutter ist Ende 50 oder Anfang 60, habe ich gesagt.
Also die ist jetzt 9, 50 oder 60 jetzt.
59, ich habe ein paar.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, der ist gesund.
Er ist gesund.
Er ist gesund, ja.
Und was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Berthurt?
Ich bin Lehrer, aber ich bin jetzt seit der Diagnose jetzt kranker gewesen.
Ich bin jetzt in der Eingliederung.
Ein Gliederung?
Ja, also mit wenigen Stunden anfangen und dann langsam steigern.
Arbeiten Sie zum Beispiel teilweise?
Ja, so kann man das sagen.
Haben Sie Stress im Leben und in der Arbeit?
Ja, das ist normale, glaube ich.
Stress? Ich weiß nicht.
So wie jeder, ich bin nicht zu sagen, dass ich unter Stress bin.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin alle entstehend.
Haben Sie feste Partnerin?
Momentan nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, glaube ich, keine Kinder.
Sie wohnen alleine?
Ich wohn alleine, ja.
Sind Sie verständlich gegen Corona?
Gegen Corona bin ich geimpft worden, ja, jetzt im Herbst nochmal, ja.
Ja, zweimal, dreimal, wieviel Mal.
Also, wir sind mittlerweile fünf Mal, glaube ich, schon.
Okay.
Sind Sie in Letzter Zeit ins Ausland gewesen?
Herr Bertolt?
Also, nicht in den letzten zwei Jahren, vielleicht nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Sport regelmäßig?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Traum und Verletzung?
Ich habe es nicht verstanden, Entschuldigung.
Verletzung?
Nein, ich höre nämlich nicht mehr.
Herr Bertolt, sind Sie in Krankenhaus, außer diese Krankheit,
stationäre, waren Sie?
War stationär, also vor anderthalb Jahren, als die Geschichte anfing,
dann war ich stationär und dann musste auch wegen der Operation.
Also ich war da immer wieder beim Krankenhaus, manchmal so 200-300,
war ich am Stück im Krankenhaus, ja.
Okay.
Herr Bertolt, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen für Sie gestattet.
Möchtest du etwas, Sophie, etwas?
Was denken Sie, Frau Doktor, ist das wieder ein Schub vom Mobbyskron,
den ich habe, oder was denken Sie?
Herr Bertolt, ich danke für Sie,
einen wegen vielleicht früher Operationen,
vielleicht eine wieder darmbruhschluss.
Darmbruhschluss.
Nein, darmbruhschluss.
Darmbruhschluss?
Darmbruhschluss.
Aber ich bin ja nicht sicher, Herr Bertolt.
Ich habe etwas, ich brauche etwas Untersuchungen.
Sie sollten nicht sterben bleiben und bitte lasst uns positiv denken.
Ich brauche einmal körperliche Untersuchungen,
ich habe schon so einen Abdäumen durchgeführt.
Nach der Untersuchung können wir wieder sprechen.
Alles klar, kann ich etwas trinken oder was meinst du?
Nein, bitte nicht.
Wir geben für Sie ihren armen Van Flüssigkeit.
Sie geben es mir in Position.
Nein, bitte nicht trinken Sie.
Vielleicht brauchen Sie einen Operationen und sollten ungefähr 4 Stunden nicht sterben.
Alles klar, okay.
Gut, ja.
Sollte ich Ihnen noch einmal meine Medikamentliste geben?
Ja, bitte, es wäre nett, wenn Sie geben.
Dann kann ich Ihnen noch einmal die Telefonnummer von meinem Gastroenterologen geben.
Oh, ist super, ja.
Ich werde Ihnen einen Kontakt künft.
Das wäre nett, vielen Dank.
Und denken Sie, Ihr Krankenhaus ist für solche Fälle geeignet
oder meinen Sie, das wäre aber anders besser, wenn man eine Operation machen müsste?
Herr Bertolt, wir sind eine Profi-Synannte.
Machen Sie sich keine Stress.
Ja, alles klar, okay.
Vielen Dank, Herr Lokton.
Danke.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Darf ich fragen?
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen, Lindert oder Verstärkte?
Was meinen Sie?
Was, woran denken Sie da?
Ja, ich meine vielleicht eine bestimmte Essen oder eine bestimmte Lage, Position,
das die Schmerzen, Lindert oder Verstärkte.
Also, wenn ich mich hinsetze, ist es besser als im Legeln, ja.
Und wenn ich erbrauchen habe, wird es auch besser.
Auch besser.
Wenn ich das trinke, dann wird es schlechter.
Ist Ihnen Nachtschweiß aus, oder Stärkfrost aufgefallen?
Nachtschweiß nicht.
Also, ich habe jetzt, bevor ich erbrechen musste,
habe ich so einen Schweißausbruch gehabt,
aber sonst Nachtschweiß kann ich nichts sagen.
Das hatte ich damals mal gehabt, als die Kanäle aktiv war, aber jetzt aktuell nicht.
Darf ich?
Bitte schön.
Wie sieht das Erbruch hinaus?
Sehr gute Frage, jawohl.
Grün nicht, aber teilweise auch übel riechend.
Gute Frage.
War kein Glut dabei?
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Und auch kein Kaffeesatz.
Aber übel riechend bräunlich.
Und fühlen Sie sich Ihren Bauch wie eine Brät-Hart?
Wenn die Schmerzen sind, ist der Bauch hart, ja.
Das müssen Sie dann entscheiden, wenn Sie untersuchen, ob der Bauch Brät-Hart ist oder nicht.
Aber der Bauch ist gespannt, ja.
Aber ich fahre mich, meine Frau.
Was ist das Problem bei dem Wasserlösen?
Keine bisher.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlucken?
Beim Schlucken nicht, nein.
Also keine Dysphage.
So, weitere Fragen.
Ist Ihnen Blähungen gern aufgefallen?
Blähungen, Sie meinen Windabgang, hat er nicht gehabt, ne?
Seit zwei Tagen, also keine Blähungen, kein Windabgang, ja.
Zwei Fragen, also die wichtigsten Sachen sind, glaube ich, gefragt worden.
Ich glaube, die Vorleuchter hat auch nach möglichen extraintestinalen Manifestationen auch gefragt, ne?
Mit Gelenkproblemen oder Hautproblemen oder Augenproblemen,
die in der physischen Form von extraintestinalen Manifestationen von Morbus Grün hat er auch jetzt nicht gehabt, aktuell, ne?
Gut.
Vielleicht hätten Sie noch Gewicht, hat er gesagt, letzten drei Mal der Konstant.
Davor hat er aber, als die Diagnose gesteckt worden ist, ungefähr 15 kg abgenommen während der Erstdiagnose
und die letzten Mal wieder drei, vier Kilo zugenommen.
Also es war zuletzt besser geworden.
Okay, wenn keine weiteren Fragen sind, können wir zur Oberarztvorstellung gehen, ne?
Ja.
Können wir als als Geist über anfangen, ne?
Ja, bitte schön.
Ja, hallo, schönen guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Darf ich?
Es geht um Herr Thomas Bert Holt, er ist 30 Jahre alt, 70 kg schwer und 1,85 m groß.
Herr Bert Holt stammt sich bei uns wegen, seit gestern, vormittag, 5 Jahren, in Laufeder seit Zunehmenden,
sehr stärke, stärke, stärke abdominalische Märzchen vor.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 7 bis 8 von auf den NS, auf den NS.
Die Schmerzen wurden keine Ausstrahlung, aber die Physische Märzchen sein.
Ja, außer dem Haber, außer dem Gab er an, da sich Märzchen krampartige, krampartige und William Formige gewesen sein.
Herr Bert Holt, darüber hinaus seien die folgenden Begleitzentrumen aufgefallen, wie nausea, mermais, erbrochen, bauch, ich habe keinen Moment.
Wie sah das Erbohrner aus, haben Sie ihn gefragt?
Ja, diese Erbrochen sind grün und gegrün, aber kein Brut.
Ja, und er hat darüber hinaus, außer dem Haber, seit Reitzag, keine Defokation gehabt.
Das habe keine geholfen, mitgebracht.
Die Fragen nach FIBA, Herzproblemen, Missionproblemen, düstene Atomot wurden verneint.
Anforderkrankungen seien die folgenden Bekannt.
Vor zwei Jahre, vor einer anderen Jahre, habe er Morbus Crohn diagnostiziert.
Mit der Medikamentanamnese, er gab ein Name von Vitamin D Tabletin 2000, einheitend üniert in der Woche.
2000, ja.
Ein Name, das regelmäßig 1 Tabletin, 1 Mal, und Vitamin B12, Intramuskulär, geschnitten.
Auch Vollzeitetabletin, einmal eingenommen, aber er hat eine Laktoseintoleranz, die sich beaufgibt.
Die Medikamentanamnese, 5 Teile, 5 Teile.
Ich muss 8, 5, 8, 5 Jahre Nikotin konsum.
Aber er sei unter halb Jahren nach dem Morbus Crohn Diagnose middam rachum auf Söhörn.
Er rach Ertrikennisch Alkohol und Tumdrogen konsumiert in Fernand.
Die Familie Anamnese ergab arterielle Hypertonie und Mio-Kartinfarktösisch Baydan Fatah
und die Abethis melltütsübtsvail, so wie Romötet Arthritis Baydam Muta.
Er habe einen Bruder, er sei gesund.
Er ist ein Lehrer von Beruf, aber seit einigen Jahren
muss er teilweise Teilzeitarbeiten machen.
Er hat nicht so viel Stress in der Eibars und im Leben.
Er wohnt allein, er sei ledig und er wohnt allein.
Er hat keine Kinder.
Er sei verständlich gegen auch FIFA Corona.
Er betriebe keinen Sport.
Ins Ausland reisen Anamnese wurden verneint.
Der Anamnese hat mehr von den Einstellungen als vom Thema.
Die Fernseher diagnostischen Morbus Crohn haben keine Beine.
Die die Diagnostik kommen, die die Physiöe bach, die Schmerzen, die Medzentriale, die Medzentriale ischemie, die Akute Pocratitis, die Leitschmerzen, die Limous, die Abschleise, die Betracht.
Ja.
sollte sich meinen Verdacht bestätigen.
Alles klar. Haben Sie den Patienten untersucht? Beschreiben Sie mal den Untersuchungsbuch vom Bauch.
Ja, ich habe schon gemacht.
Ja, ich meine schon.
Ja, er habe Verspannung und Druckschmerzen.
Ja, ganz diffusiv Schmerzen.
Abverspannung und Druckschmerzen, ja.
Ja, ich habe ausgültasisch gemacht, aber ich habe nicht gehört.
Haben Sie bei der Palpation Abverspannung und Druckschmerzen Resistenzen getastet?
Ja, kontr-leteral.
Bei der Beschreibung vom Abdehminalkörperlichen Untersuchungsbefund ist erst, wie Sie gesagt haben,
Frage Druckschmerz, wenn ja, wo, bei ihm war das diffus, dann Abverspannung, lokalisiert oder diffus
und dann kann man noch als Besonderheit, wenn der Bauch sehr stark abvergespannt ist, sagen,
zum Beispiel dieser bär-tarte Bauch, das wäre eine Option.
Und dann kann man noch beschreiben, ob Sie Resistenzntasten, wenn Sie Resistenzntasten, wie die Konsistenz ist und wo die sind,
zum Beispiel oberen Quadranten oder oberen recht Quadranten oder so weiter.
Das kann man beschreiben, hat aber nicht gehabt, ja.
Man hat nur Abverspannung, diffusor, Druckschmerz und hat der Zeichen einer Peritonitis.
Haben Sie ihn getestet oder wie testen Sie das?
Ja, ich habe schon getestet.
Ich habe Abverspannung, der dort ist, Peritonitis vielleicht.
Ich habe auch digitaler Untersuchung durchgeführt.
Aber ich weiß nicht.
Also, am Pulle war frei und Sie hatten kein Blut am Fingerling, ja, das ist gut.
Und jetzt haben Sie noch, sagen Sie, nach der Palpation haben Sie auch Auskultation gemacht,
ich habe nicht gehört.
Wie lange haben Sie drauf gehört?
Ja, ich muss 4, 1 Minuten, 4 Quadranten, 7 Min.
Jetzt haben Sie aber eine andere Stelle nicht ganz genau hingehört,
wo waren Sie schon?
Er hatte hochgestellte Darmgeräusche.
Was ja auch zu Ihrer Diagnose, Verdachtsdiagnose passt, gell?
Was sind hochgestellte Darmgeräusche?
Wie kann man die noch bezeichnen?
Hochgestellte.
Was heißt hochgestellte?
Gibt es einen anderen Begriff dafür für hochgestellte Darmgeräusche?
Und wie lange?
Was sind hochgestellte Darmgeräusche?
Was stehen Sie darunter vor?
Vor dem Ilios, vor dem Ilios Anfang,
diese hochgestellte Darmgeräusche, dann haben Sie es aufgesucht.
Was ist das?
Wie hört sich das an?
Ich kenne es, mir können Sie.
Klingende Darmgeräusche.
Schon mal gehört so ein mechanischen Ilios,
für die Kollegen, die es geschrieben haben.
Sie haben ja Verdacht auf die Anrufung.
Man kann auch sagen, klingende Darmgeräusche
oder metallische Geräusche,
wie aus aufs Offen so ein hohen Kanisterschlagen.
Das sind klingende oder hochgestellte klingende
oder metallische Geräusche,
die ein Hinweis geben können auf ein mechanischen Ilios,
die Widerstandsperistaltik.
Wenn Sie gar nichts hören, wie Sie es gesagt haben,
Sie haben überall jeden Quadranten 3 Minuten, 5 Minuten gehört
und nichts gehört.
Was ist das dann?
Perforation.
Kann sein, aber kann auch ohne Perforation sein.
Ilios, todo stiller Bauch.
Genau.
Wieso hört man das Todes stille?
Interessant.
Parallelität.
Man hört die Glockenleuten.
Was hört man da?
Wenn Sie Glück haben, hören Sie den Ortenpuls
oder die Ortenpulsation.
Wenn der Bauch stille, nennt man auch deswegen
Todes stille.
Aber wie hört man das Krankheitsbild,
wenn man viel ist,
dass Sie keine Darmgeräusche haben.
Darmgeräusche sind entweder verstärkt oder sperrlich,
wenn Sie gar keine haben, nennt man das.
Wie nennt man das?
Wir haben einmal die mechanischen Ilios
mit den hochgestellten Darmgeräuschen.
Parallelitische Ilios.
Genau.
Also dieser Patient hat ein mechanischen Ilios,
die haben hochgestellte Darmgeräusche.
Sie haben auch Ultraschall gemacht.
Viel Gas.
Kann man sehen, manchmal, ja, was noch.
Und mechanische Ilios.
Ja, wegen dieser ...
Mechanische Ilios.
Viele Kerlstoffen.
Die können die Darmschlägen sehen,
manchmal.
Weitere Darmschlägen zum Beispiel,
kann man sehen, Ultraschall,
wenn man ein mechanisches Ilios ist.
Oder bei Parallelitischen Ilios kann man
auch mal eine Pendelperistaltik sehen.
Also Erweiterung von Darmschlägen kann man
Ultraschall sehen.
Und was machen Sie dann als weiterer Test,
wenn Sie Verdacht haben auf mechanischen Ilios?
Also Sie haben Klinik
und so eine Grafisch-Verdacht
auf mechanischen Ilios.
Was machen Sie dann noch?
Ja, CT abdomen, vielleicht,
wenn ich nicht sicher.
Und wenn Sie raus sind, noch kein CT haben.
Was machen Sie dann?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Natürlich,
wenn ich nicht abdumme.
Was sieht man bei mechanischen Ilios
und Röntgen abdummen? Was kann man sehen?
Ja, kann man die eine
Gas- und
die Steigende ...
Wie nennt man das,
was man Röntgen will, dann sieht,
beim Ilios, beim mechanischen Ilios?
Ja, ja.
Zäpensteigende.
Wenn die Darm-Schlinge
so mit
der Linie.
Luft und
Wasser.
Ja, wie nennt man das?
Was büchern wir nicht?
Dünndarm-Spiegel.
Also Stehende, Stehen, Stingeln
und Spiegelbildungen.
Das kann Ihnen sein
auf Ilios.
Was kann man noch sehen,
im Röntgen, hat ein Kollege gerade geschrieben,
also können auch freie Luft erkennen,
falls eine Perforation sich da hinter verbergen sollte.
Aber beim mechanischen Ilios
ist das nicht unbedingt der Fall.
Also Sie sehen im Röntgenbild
Stehende,
Dünndarm-Schlinge und Spiegelbildungen.
Als Hinweis auf, ja.
Okay, aber dann machen Sie bei der Anamnese,
natürlich haben Sie es richtig aber gesagt,
wenn es jetzt nicht ganz, ganz akut ist,
dann können Sie uns das auch noch ein bisschen sehen.
Okay, und im CT können Sie dann die Ursache
in der Persone erkennen.
Was gibt es denn für Ursachen
für mechanischen Ilios bei den Patienten?
Ja, Crypt-Apses,
Crypt-Apses, Fistel.
Ja, Fistel,
Abses, ja, hat da eine Anamnese
für Abses?
Ja, wir gehen ab,
ich wurde operiert vor 2 Jahren,
wegen Anapses
und Anapyrin.
Abses kann sein, intraptomnell,
aber spricht die Klinik dafür,
dass es ein Abses eher ist oder eher unwahrscheinlich?
Unwahrscheinlich, seit...
Warum?
Er ist gerade keine
Durchfälle und
kein Fieber.
Genau, also keine, sag ich mal,
absesbücheren Symptome, ja.
Was gibt es noch, außer Abses für Ursachen
für einen mechanischen Ilios?
Außer Abses für einen mechanischen Ilios.
Ja, die
Stuhl, Kot.
Kot, kann man sagen, ja.
Gibt es noch manchmal, ja.
Was noch?
Bei den Patienten am wahrscheinlichsten
wegen der Anamnese?
Ja, wegen der Operationen.
Operationen und
Nehen, Sikloresis.
Ja, und was passiert da, wenn
wir operiert worden sind?
Ja, nachdem Operationen
eine Anwachsung...
Verwachsung, ja.
Wie nennt man das dann, wenn es durch
Verwachsung ist, dieses Ilios, durch Verwachsung?
Verwachsung.
Irgendwas, wie nenn ich das?
Irgendwas kann auch mal eine Ursache sein,
aber bei Verwachsung ist meistens so ein
Strang im Darm zu sehen, wie nennt man das dann?
Das hat ein bestimmter Begriff.
Verwachsen.
Verwachsen war richtig, ja.
Briehden Ilios, schon mal gehört, Briehden Ilios?
Briehden Ilios.
Nach postoperativer Briehden Ilios, ja.
Das wäre bei dem Patientverdachsdiagnose.
Okay.
Was machen Sie denn mit den Patienten,
jetzt akut?
Also mit Teilparameter ist noch gut, aber er bricht es.
Darf nichts essen, haben Sie nüchtern gelassen,
gehört?
Nazogastrische Sonne,
Sondar, Türi, Stein.
Sehr gut, jawohl. Was machen Sie denn noch?
Supasmonitikum intravenous
ja, Schleur.
Und,
Was machen Sie denn noch?
Ja, mit der Kloprometer.
Ja,
mehr oder weniger.
Mehr oder weniger.
Ja,
weil es ja auch motiviert steigern ist,
aber es kann nicht den Schmerzen verstärken.
Absolut,
abfühlen mit seinen Rechten.
Also wenn Sie CT gemacht haben,
Sie haben ein Briehden Ilios,
dann macht man nichts,
dann macht man mit Abführmast,
oder was macht man dann?
Sie haben eine halbe Runde gelegene Fusion gegeben,
Schmerzmedikament, Spass-Müdiker,
ist alles gut.
Und als nächstes macht man dann was?
Opel.
Ja, man muss operieren,
dann müssen Sie die Briehden Verwachsungen lösen,
damit man das dann beheben kann.
Ja, alles klar.
Gut,
war
schwierig.
Kopf, Kopf.
Was geben Sie?
Viele, viele Essen immer schreiben,
aber für mich
schwer, ich hoffe,
Sie haben die Diagnose richtig gestellt,
Sie haben mir von Anfang an gesagt,
das ist am ehesten ein prosto-parative Ilios,
mechanische Ilios, war alles korrekt.
Ich will nur so versuchen,
Sie in Gespräche zu verwickeln,
damit Sie mir antworten können,
damit ich merke, ob Sie gut Deutsch sprechen können oder nicht.
Ach.
Sie haben mir gut gemacht, Sie haben auf alles geantwortet.
Inhalt ist manchmal nicht so wichtig.
Gut.
Jetzt Kommentare.
Es gibt es im Chat ganz viele Kommentare,
aber ich glaube, die mir da auch zu antworten,
glaube ich,
Briehden Ilios,
Schwulze, Kloros,
Vyluft, ja.
Ja.
Ja, bei uns,
Morbus Kron, ja,
Differenzial Diagnose
ist ja auch sehr wichtig.
Kann auch mal ein Schub von Morbus Kron sein,
gibt es auch manchmal,
aber dann wäre die Symptome vielleicht ein bisschen anders,
aber das wäre auch ein Differenzial Diagnose trotzdem.
Also, die Oberbegriff
bei dieser Patientin ist
mechanische Ilios
bei Morbus Kron, ja.
Ich habe nicht vergeben,
bei Morbus Kron.
Oder Briehden Ilios
Ja.
Ich habe alles besprochen, gefragt.
Was haben wir hier zu fragen?
Herr Scham,
Parallelitik Ilios
wie auch das,
wie du es auch noch machen kannst?
Wir machen es auf Deutsch,
Parallelitik Ilios ist,
wenn sich der Darf nicht mehr bewegt.
Also,
es steht.
Kann auch mal als Spätfolge eines
mechanischen Ilios entstehen.
Also, mechanische Ilios kann manchmal ein Parallelitik Ilios übergehen.
Aber wenn man mich beim
Primär Parallelitik Ilios
haben sie andere Ursachen häufig.
Also, zum Beispiel, eine Peritomitis
oder
andere Probleme, zum Beispiel
Tumorerkrankungen
durch eine Peritonealkatznose,
können wir auch Parallelitik Ilios machen.
Muss ich unterbrechen
diese Fall?
Nein, das war gut, wir unterbrechen ja.
Also, dass die Vitalparameter machen
und so weiter war gut.
Stabiler konnte ja mit ihnen reden.
Man hätte jetzt gesagt,
Aua, Aua, Aua und so weiter, wissen Sie ja.
Das kann ich manchmal schon machen.
Aber es war gut, dass sie gesagt haben,
wir müssen kurz unterbrechen,
ich muss jetzt mal checken, ob es ein Notfall ist,
wo wir direkt etwas machen müssen
und ob wir die anderen Mese weitermachen können.
War gut.
Eine gute Lösung.
Also, es ist ein Immunziposition.
Ja, Immunziposition, ja.
Viele Nebunwirkungen.
Die Nebunwirkungen machen richtig.
Kann auch infektioß sein,
dass sie durch Immunziposition Infektionen
bekommen können, ob da mit der Infektion
gibt es auch mal.
Aber dann werden die Symptome
vielleicht ein bisschen anders.
Aber ist eine wichtige
Differenzialjagd muss auch.
Muss man jede Quadrant abdomen?
Wie viele Minuten auskultieren?
Ja, wenn Sie an einer Stelle
hören, dass es Hochstelltamen geräuchten,
dann müssen Sie nicht alle Quadranten hören.
Aber man sollte schon
versuchen, so grob einzugrenzen.
Dass es sagt, ist es eher im rechten
Oberbau, eher im rechten Unterbau
und so weiter.
Das ist immer ganz hilfreich
für die Diagnose Stellung.
Ich meine, wie viele Minuten?
Eine Minute, zwei, drei, sie haben.
Also, wenn es eine richtige
Paralyse ist, sollten Sie schon mindestens
mal fünf Minuten drauf hören.
Insgesamt mal.
Also mindestens ein paar Minuten
mal versuchen zu hören.
Aber nicht
nicht zwangliess Sekunden,
dann sagen die Paralyse, sondern immer
mal weiter hören, so ein paar Minuten.
Ich kenne das keine Empfehlung,
wie lange man machen muss,
ein paar Minuten und nicht immer drauf hören.
Bei Peritonitis ab der Spannung
und gibt es
die andere.
Was gibt es noch
bei Peritonitis für ein Problem
oder ein Untersuchungsergeb,
die Sie gefunden haben?
Das, was Sie auch bei McBurnie
eigentlich auch testen.
Was testen Sie da?
Affanities.
Ja, aber was testen Sie da?
Ja, aber
Durkefür,
Durkschmerzen.
Loslaschmerzen.
Also bei Peritonismus ist es so,
dass Sie die,
zum Beispiel auch ein Erschütterungschmerz auslösen können.
Das heißt, wenn Sie auf den Bauch klopfen,
dann können Sie alle Schmerzen machen.
Erschütterungschmerz.
Ja.
Oder als Loslaschmerz
oder Hochschmerz.
Ich schütte
Schütterungschmerz.
Ja.
Auf Erspannung.
Okay.
Okay, danke schön.
Alles klar.
Weitere Kommentare oder Fragen?
Was ist unser Teil?
Die Operation
die Operation
der Mechanische
die Operation, also der Mechanische
das ist der Oberbegriff.
Und darunter gibt es verschiedene Ursachen.
Brieben können eine Ursache sein
und Wagenation können eine Ursache sein
Strikturen kann eine Ursache sein
Wohlwollos oder Traumvertragungen im Material, wo es kein Ursache sein,
das sind Formen des mechanischen Illos.
Mechanische Illos ist dann der Oberbegriff.
Okay, danke.